there's just one episode left for the
cast at NCIS LA the series finale airs
Sunday on CBS we got some cast
confessions from the Stars revealing
what they stole from the set I got all
the goodies
I got my best I got my vest
um I got my badge oh you did you had two
badges and I asked for both badges so I
could eventually give it one to each kid
and on the badges is still my photograph
from season one
the weight set I took the weight set
from the gym and a bunch of Jordans
wearing them right now let's go like
that yep those are those are some of the
shoes that I stole these are directly
stolen from Seth I was thinking about
putting the in my backyard
of course over 14 seasons and 323
episodes there's been highs lows and a
whole lot of action
et's been there from the start in 2009
we met the cast during a special
two-part NCIS episode that served as a
backdoor pilot for the spin
yes I got hit by a car today that was a
lot of fun
foreign
big American job so yeah I'm pretty
excited
I would literally ask writers to write
more you know fight sequences this is
how somebody gets hurt
parts of the show
the explosions we had in the show was
just unbelievable
action and these bombs just start going
in flames
it became second nature but it was
amazing
pyro a lot of explosions a lot of guns
it was it was it was fun we are rolling
now
there's no hope for me
in the middle keep it up I'm gonna
bounce you off a rock I will see him
more yeah now that we're not working
this one man like we look we worked
together for four little Baby Bjorn he's
gonna carry me around town
cozy it's gonna be great it'll be great
Chris needs your milk
and we've got so many more laughs
stories and emotional moments from the
NCIS LA family in an hour-long special
that airs right after the series
farewell you guys just watched the
finale lots of feels I
pinch me I wasn't expecting that ended
there are new interviews plus we opened
the ET Vault to bring you 14 years of
behind the scenes Secrets I forgot how
happy dance makes me she won't talk
about this but she was on Dancing With
the Stars in Portugal and I think she
won
CBS presents a salute to NCIS Los
Angeles and Entertainment Tonight
Special Air Sunday on CBS and streams on
Paramount Plus you know we ended on top
and and that's a beautiful thing
foreign